hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
you really are seeing this a GTA 5 video
years after the game first released back
in 2013 how old do you feel right now
that open-world Rockstar gave us
presented so many opportunities to
discover hidden law on a huge detailed
island packed with so many secrets
almost seven years later fans are still
scratching their heads wondering whether
or not we'll ever have answers so I put
this to you can you crack these unsolved
mysteries in GTA 5 and GTA online let's
see how deep these rabbit holes go let's
start things off with one of the most
detailed drawn-out mysteries in GTA 5 a
blood-soaked breadcrumb trail that seems
to lead to one man the so called
infinity killer first things first we
need to find out exactly who was behind
these gruesome acts and how much damage
he was able to do get your butt over to
Sandy shores and you can find a rundown
house with a newspaper clipping attached
to the wall it says that a man named
Merle Abraham's the suspected infinity
killer died in prison while awaiting
trial for abduction and torture he is
believed to have had eight victims who
were all single young men that were
eliminated whilst jogging while the
police acknowledged his weird obsession
with the number eight they say that no
bodies were ever found but I'm not happy
with that I feel we can do better than a
Los Santos Police Department you with me
not so far away from the site of the
newspaper clipping you can find another
rundown Shack some people think it was
Abraham's house whereas others think
this is his kill house man that sounds
eerie all I know is that it gives us an
even deeper look into Merle's obsession
with the number eight and his origins as
the infinity killer written here on the
wall is there will be eight a reference
to the total number of victims he plans
on tallying up you can also see a small
illustration above the message no I
don't think it's a mountain
it looks more important so remember that
for now in the next room we can find the
message eight is just infinity stood up
which is probably where that name the
infinity killer actually
from oh and there's also a pair of
jogging shoes hanging from the ceiling
nice touch
I guess anyway heading over to Sonora
National Park not far from Mel's home we
find another set of clues between a
smattering of number eight strewn across
the rocks you can find the infinity
killers attempt at a bit of light poetry
one is done two is for fun three tried
to run four called Mom fives not alive
six is Nick's what the hell does that
mean seven is in heaven eight won't wait
touching stuff it's enough to confirm
the number of murrells victims but we
don't get the actual clue until we find
this message left near by they want me
they have me but they'll never get my
people even though I shall leave them
sign enough where they put me the key
message here is actually in that final
line where they put me as we already
know by now
Abraham's was eventually arrested and
died before he could face trial so what
would we find if we went to search his
presumed final resting place bolingbroke
penitentiary surprise surprise we get
yet another message from the infinity
killer where water meets land and fire
one spewed forth there the infinity
eight shall stay until I return this is
getting deep now the more interesting
part of the message is his little
drawing right next to it remember the
one I told you about earlier well this
is actually a slightly more detailed
version of the same subject matter and
now it's clear to see that no it's still
not a mountain it's actually a map he
even gave us a little handy compass
pointing north
she is Mel you're a good'n head up to
that area in the ocean to the north of
los santos and you'll find what all of
this has been leading up to the bodies
hidden under water amongst small rocks
you can find them wrapped up and laid to
rest at the bottom of the ocean whilst
we have found what the police were
unable to it doesn't exactly leave this
mystery solved there are still many
loose ends to tie up and there have been
lots of speculation online surrounding
the killer some people believe that he
made himself the eighth victim which
would make sense given his message
earlier eight won't wait referring to
the fact that he wouldn't wait to face
trial that ties him pretty well others
believe that merle may still be alive
and well ready to reveal himself once
again as hinted by one of his previous
messages which ended with the ominous
line until i read
turn but what do you think about the
infinity killer case was Merle the
eighth victim or does he still walk the
streets of Los Santos let me know what
you think about this and if you find any
more clues get them in the comments
below please right after our exhaustive
journey into the mind of a serial killer
how about something a little less
intense off the east coast of Los Santos
something strange lies underwater it's
deep enough that I would recommend using
a submarine to get here but dive down
and you'll see a small hatch on the
ocean floor
with a small rectangular window a word
of warning though gta5 oceans have a
kill zone a depth at which your
character will die after presumably
being crushed by the pressure
conveniently the Death Zone starts just
above the hatch so you need to be very
careful here if you want to investigate
this for yourself still these setbacks
don't stop us we came here for a clue
not long after you arrived a light comes
on from the other side of the window
which implies there is some kind of
human life on the other side but there's
no way to actually interact with the
hatch itself hang around the hatch for a
decent amount of time for me it was like
90 seconds and you'll eventually start
hearing Morse code being tapped out from
within here's the weird thing though
while you'd expect a message to cry out
for help or maybe greeting of some sort
it's actually a joke at the expense of a
character in GTA 4 deciphering the
message says hey you never call how do
you fancy going bowling reference to the
frequent requests made by roman bellick
the cousin of GTA force protagonist nico
it's likely this is an easter egg to
both GTA 4 and maybe the TV show Lost
either way it's true purpose is still
uncertain so let's keep checking back
one update something may happen the
Grand Theft Auto series is no stranger
to speculation around the inclusion of
various mythical or fictional creatures
stories of monsters and beasts appearing
in the world started all the way back in
the ps2 era and they're still going
strong today let's start with the big
one
no pun intended
the multiple rumored appearances of good
old Bigfoot across various rock star
games have been subject to rampant
speculation but GTA 5 might just provide
us with the clearest looks at the facts
and fiction of this peculiar case in the
story mission predator the player is
given a rifle with a thermal scope used
to hunt down the O'Neil brothers through
the woods however if you have a closer
look around you'll find this mysterious
figure in your sights while it's
obviously matches the profile of
Bigfoots you can't shoot at it
fortunately the mystery becomes a little
easier to decipher in the mission the
last one
Franklin agrees to hunt down the Bigfoot
only to find that this particular
incarnation of the Beast is a crazy man
in a costume in a costume case closed
right well no not quite in an update
that didn't drop until two years after
the game released a playable version of
Bigfoot was added to GTA 5 accessing it
involves eating a series of golden
peyote plants which suggests that this
appearance is part of a hallucination
meaning it's hard to put the Bigfoot
mystery to bed entirely in fact Rockstar
toyed with the inclusion of a
bigfoot-like creature as recently as Red
Dead Redemption - so I wouldn't be
surprised if this one rumbled on for a
little while longer certain online
communities believe other mythical
beasts appear in GTA 5 such as the goat
man or the rat man
but despite extensive research there has
never been enough evidence to suggest
any of their alleged appearances are
real one thing's for sure though when it
comes to bizarre mythical creatures
Rockstar aren't afraid to get their
hands dirty the large majority of GTA 5
secrets and easter eggs have ties to
real-world counterparts the game is
filled to the brim with references to
various video games TV shows and movies
but every now and then you'll find an
easter egg with no clear link to any
piece of media in fact some Easter eggs
don't appear to have any link to well
anything at all one mystery that stemmed
from exactly that issue is the face in
the mountain on the northern slope of
Mount chiliad you can find a face that
has been drawn into the side of the
mountain whilst some people initially
speculated that this was the face of
Jesse Pinkman a character from the TV
show Breaking Bad it's hard to confirm
this theory with any real conviction
for a very long time people try to dig
up who the face belonged to with many
beginning to believe it was simply a
rogue developer who decided to sneak
their face into the game then something
strange happened Rockstar re-released
GTA 5 for PC and next-gen consoles
addressing this Easter Egg in the
process but rather than get rid of the
image altogether they replaced it with
this we're gonna have to blur this image
because YouTube won't like this but
behind this is a rooster that bears an
uncanny resemblance to to amount to
immense bits and pieces is that family
friendly enough you chew if you want to
see this for yourself
it's here on the map go crazy you could
be the [ __ ] of the walk the strange
thing is that this move only serves to
heighten the mystery around the easter
egg why in a game with hundreds of
risque Easter eggs did Rockstar decide
to change this one who does that
original face belong to and why did
Rockstar decide to remove them from the
updated game it's an easter egg that may
seem incidental at first but certainly
asks more questions the more you look
into it GTA 5 is filled with unusual
throwaway secrets that rarely amount to
much other than a quick joke or
reference but there is still some
interactions within the game that so far
have yet to be explained
curiously some of the sources for these
mysteries are various fond hidden within
GTA 5 that trigger strange results when
you try to call them probably the most
bizarre example of this are the black
cell phones use the in-game phone to
dial this number 1 9 9 9 3 6 7 3 7 6 7
and you'll be connected to a caller
known as black cell phones as you're
waiting to be connected an explosion
will trigger right above your
character's head what's even stranger is
that when your character gets their
phone back out the operating system that
it uses as well as the font color scheme
will both have changed there are all
kinds of theories linked to these
mysterious phone numbers some people
believe the numbers 3 6 7 3 767 are code
for EMP drop a reference to an
electromagnetic pulse that could trigger
this strange event others believe the
number is a leftover a remnant of many
explosions that are triggered using
phones in the game story mode or even
that it could be part of a mission
was cut from the story whether you think
they are a throw away secrets or a
reference to something deeper it's still
not clear what purpose these mysterious
numbers have tried for yourself in game
yeah at some point we had to talk about
aliens didn't we
while Easter eggs like the black cell
phones might hint at something unusual
happening behind the scenes in GTA 5
there are some mysteries that are far
more upfront in nature whether you made
your way through the story only once or
explored every last inch of Los Santos
there is one thing every GTA 5 player
has long worried about aliens much like
with Bigfoot Rockstar made clever use of
aliens throughout Los Santos to create
an air of uncertainty around their
existence for example in the mission did
somebody say yoga Michael son Jimmy
drugs him by giving him a drink spiked
with something questionable Michael soon
experiences a bizarre hallucination in
which he is abducted by a UFO and
examined by aliens
just like the peyote trip that allows
the players to control Bigfoot it's easy
to dismiss this appearance as a simple
hallucination and therefore believe
aliens don't exist within the world of
gta5 but as many of you know the
references and sightings go way deeper
during the prologue mission an alien can
be found through the ice in the frozen
river not only that but there are four
separate appearances of UFOs throughout
the game while it's impossible to
interact with them they most definitely
appear in the world and don't seem to be
part of an elucidation unlike some other
similar mysteries it does appear that
extraterrestrials in some shape or form
exist within the law of gta5 the part
that makes it a mystery however is the
uncertainty around the purpose they
serve as they are left unable to
interact with them or even confirm that
aliens exist within the UFOs themselves
it's another mystery that for now seems
to be a dead end that being said they
may well be connected to another of GTA
5's most famous mysteries the Mount
chiliad mystery is one of the most
curious time-consuming mysteries to ever
be featured in a video game ever since
people first discovered it back in 2013
it has been the subject of endless
rumours speculation and blind guesses as
to what it means or the purpose it
herbs inside the cable car station at
the top of Mount chiliad I'm sure you've
seen it there is a large map printed on
the wall it appears to be a map of Mount
chiliad but it contains lots of unusual
symbols including UFOs a jetpack and
what looks to be an egg that is hatching
over the years people have believed
various theories about the map some
people believe it relates to the
presence of aliens in Los Santos plywood
just looked at whereas others think this
is tied to the Illuminati and the
all-seeing eye
whatever the reason behind it nothing
could deter hardcore fans from trying to
get to the bottom of this mystery many
believe the key to this secret is
overlaying the map onto Los Santos
itself and using it to triangulate the
location of various in-game items and
secrets well this did produce some
interesting results including a
discovery of a sunken uf4 well that was
hidden underwater it didn't provide any
further clues as most of us know there
are still no jetpacks in single-player
versions of the game and the only
reference to an egg of any kind lies in
the teachings of GTA 5 s Epsilon cult
rather anticlimactically
a jetpack was added later to GTA online
as a part of the Doomsday heist which
stripped the mount chilliad mystery of
much of its urgency while many people
continue to find things in the open
world we are no closer to finding a
breakthrough in GTA 5 s largest most
fascinating mystery to date we are
missing something but what could that be
could you be the person to unravel this
mystery and go down in folklore as a
legend regardless of the community's
progress however it's still really cool
to see something so small generate so
much intrigue and become such a lasting
part of the game almost seven years
later for now though this is one mystery
that remains unsolved I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade thank you for your
time if you got to the end of the video
can you tell me who would win in a fight
between Trevor Michael and Franklin
my money's on Trevor thanks for your
time I'll see you next time